-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That is, as always,
great to hear.
Let's get to the news.
The Electoral College
met today to affirm
President-elect Joe Biden's win.
Great! The guy hasn't even
taken office yet,
but his election victory
is already in its second term.
We're going to be seeing
articles about Biden fatigue
before Christmas.
"The Wall Street Journal"
published an op-ed on Friday
that said future First Lady,
Dr. Jill Biden,
should not use
the honorific "Doctor"
because she has
a PhD in education
and is not a medical doctor.
It also asked her to
start going by Mrs. Woman,
and if they need her attention
they'll just point at her.
After several
news outlets reported
that top White House officials
were scheduled
to begin receiving the
coronavirus vaccine this week,
President Trump
tweeted last night
that he didn't want staffers
receiving injections early -
not unless they can figure out
a way to overturn
the results of the election.
Uh-oh!
It's time for
a smart-joke alert.
[ Alarm blaring ]
I think, technically,
it's time for a smart joke
and then there
would be an alert.
That's right -- several
news outlets reported yesterda
that top White House
officials were scheduled
to begin receiving the
coronavirus vaccine this week.
Well, you know what they say -
to the vector go the spoils.
I mean, it's smart.
Not sure it's a joke.
That joke can call itself
"Doctor," for all I care.
The pharmaceutical company
Pfizer, yesterday,
began shipping its newly
approved coronavirus vaccine
from a facility in Michiga
with protection from
the U.S. Marshals Service.
Said one U.S. Marshal,
"Oh, these?
No. These are PS5s."
In a new editorial --
Why do they have U.S. Marshals
"Give us those vaccines!
I got the vaccines, Bob.
I don't know.
I don't know
much about them at all.
I heard this vector joke."
In a new editorial today,
"The Wall Street Journal"
called on President Trump
to concede the election,
but they wanted to
make sure he saw it,
so they published it in "Maxim."
New York Governor --
[ Laughs ]
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
announced on Friday
that he would halt indoor dining
at bars and restaurants
across the state to stop
the spread of the coronavirus.
So, of course, that only applies
to indoor-indoor dining,
not outdoor-indoor dining.
A hospital in Latvia
recently installed
an automated vending machine
that dispenses
coronavirus test kits.
While, in America,
we don't have that,
and no one knows
where Latvia is.
According to a new study,
dogs can detect
the presence of the coronaviru
in human sweat.
So maybe it's best Trump
didn't get a dog,
because it would have
barked itself to death.
The Cleveland Indians
baseball team
has reportedly decided to change
its name after 105 years.
So Cleveland is doing it.
Washington's football team
is doing it.
Ball's in your court, Indiana.
Wally, I didn't know they were
also changing the name
of Cleveland.
Could we look at the card
real quick?
Can we go back one card?
-Yeah.
-There we go.
Definitely not the spellin
of Cleveland.
-Isn't it known for knives
-Can we flip back one more card?
Can we go back one more card
-Yeah, sure.
-Got it wrong twice.
-[ Laughs ]
-The consistency is what
I respect out of it.
And, finally -- We got to ge
an alert for Wally.
And, finally,
Disney announced last week
that actor Harrison Ford
will return
for a fifth "Indiana Jones
movie in July 2022.
In this one,
he breaks into a tomb
and then tries to remember
why he went in there.
And that, you guys --
that was the monologue.